a lot of strikes going on at the moment
you're being very Resolute as things
stand in standing up to the unions not
proving very popular to the public again
three quarters think the Indians have
got the edge in this at the moment
I want to talk specifically about nurses
mainly because your father was an NHS GP
your mother ran the Family Pharmacy
you're a person who grew up
around the health system around
Healthcare it must burn in your soul
nurses we were told to go out and
applaud every Thursday in the pandemic
many of them died in the pandemic
risking their life to save people's
lives they to me should be made an
exception and yet you barely negotiated
with the nursing unions do you not feel
this Duty that you talked about to
actually take care of nurses and say
actually we do have to make some
exceptions and at top of my list my
priority is going to be nurses and give
them a proper pay rise
you know you're you're right nurses
should be an exception and that's
because they do an incredible job for
all of us and they demonstrated that
during the pandemic and I'm really
grateful to them for that and you're
right I grew up in an NHS family so this
does burn deeply inside of me because I
know how important great health care is
for people and including my own family
and we did treat them as an exception
you know people forget that actually
during during covid when I was
Chancellor we instituted a public sector
pay for ease because actually wages for
most people were were going down and
what we decided in that context given
everything going on that there should be
a pay freeze across the entire public
sector so everyone working in the public
sector didn't see their wages rise
during covid given the economic
situation but you know what there was
one exception to all of that it was
people working in the NH yeah but if it
was nursing I know but it's right it's
already completely dwarfed as you know
by inflation but hang on a bit your
principle though that yeah that we
should treat is one that I agree with
and it's one that I've actually
delivered when I was Chancellor
and then when we're talking about this
and I'm really glad actually that to
have an opportunity to talk about it now
look it's not always easy in this job
because I'm focused on doing what I
believe is right for the country and in
the long term and often that means doing
things that maybe not always popular and
this is a good example of that but let
me explain why we're doing what we're
doing and why I think it's important
look I would love right I would love to
give the nurses a massive pay rise who
wouldn't certainly would make my life
easier wouldn't it right of course I
would love to do that if I could give
them on them so why is that tough right
why is it tough it's it's about choices
so right now there's a record amount of
money going into the NHS record amount
and in spite of those difficult
decisions that we had to make to
stabilize the economy which with the
right decisions we found more money for
the NHS and social care because I
believe that was the right thing to do
so right now money going to the NHS
because it's ever been but we have to
put that in lots of different places we
need to hire more doctors more nurses we
need more scanning equipment
if we need more ambulances I understand
but to do that to to recruit people
you've got to make them think there's an
environment that's worth working in that
they're going to be actually treated in
the way that we treated them in the
pandemic with all our applauding I mean
one specific thing I really got my goat
about the nurses is in the pandemic
after a campaign which I led actually
car park charges were removed from all
hospitals for nurses right because they
were paying up to a thousand pounds each
a year to park their car outside a place
they were going in to save lives it
seemed to be Preposterous in Scotland
and Wales they don't have that charge
but now the pandemic's over that's come
back and they're now facing charges
again of a thousand pounds a year you
can't think that's right surely the
nurses in England have to pay a thousand
pounds a year for the privilege of
parking outside a hospital to save lives
so actually what we've done is put in
place support for trust to be able to
support their students why don't you
just say enough well and just continue
what happened in the pandemic yeah well
because there's other things that we've
done for nurses as well because you're
right it's not just about Payless you
know that's not fair well there's other
ways that we can demonstrate on that
point though it's not fair is it well
everyone watching this show will get to
work in lots of different ways I know
right and but not many are actually
going to actually save lives and they're
paying a thousand pounds on average
for the pleasure of parking outside a
hospital it's ridiculous yeah and that's
why we put measures in place actually in
more funding to ease the burden of
hospital car parking actually not just
on employees but also on patients but
probably there on a regular basis that's
actually what's happened is a lot of
these trusts have actually put the
prices up they're now paying more than
nursing staff than they were before the
pandemic again I simply say dude that's
not fair is it it's not right well here
are some of the other things we're doing
right because again don't change your
subject on that it's not fair and right
is it well let me tell you some of the
other things we're doing I know you
don't think it is well look of course
what I would I love it if people have to
pay less to get to work of course I
would right and of course I'd love that
for everybody why are nurses in Scotland
and Wales valid more
they also pay higher taxes a typical
nurse in Scotland
right can you at least look at that of
course I'm happy to look at that right
of course I think you should I think
it's a big deal for a lot of users but
it's really important so here are some
of the other things that we've done and
then I want to get on to the point on
pay but so you're right because there's
lots of other ways we can value people
we've reinstituted nurses bursaries so
if you're training to be a nurse 5 000
pounds a year bursary that's not
available for people studying other
subjects that's because we care about
nurses in particular you ask they should
be treated differently they are that's
very generous something else the union
asked us for a year before last was when
nurses qualify we want to keep
supporting because they want to keep
learning new skills so they can help
more patients we said great we'll
support that thousand pounds of a
trading budget for every newly quality
but here's the problem so let's get on
to pay though so I just want to say
here's what you're not mentioning in
this contest which is Raging inflation
means that all this stuff has been
completely dwarfed so you know as well
as I do that nurses are actually out of
pocket despite all this they're
massively out of pocket because of
inflation and I think that if with
countries told to go out and applaud
these people every Thursday we're
risking their lives in a pandemic and
our reward is to kick him in the teeth
the moment it's over I don't think it's
fair so I don't think that's a fair
characterization of it I don't think
that's a fair characterization of it at
all right but look this is really
important to give me a second to explain
give me a second to explain so nurses
aren't getting a pay rise they're
getting a pay rise of about five percent
and much higher actually for lower paid
nurses so that is happening right and
and it goes back to the question of
there are all these other things that we
need to do in the NHS as well we need
more nurses we need more answers we need
more scanners no no but this is the
other thing is about so look I don't
think anyone watching this show would
you as well would say okay great we need
to put up everyone's taxes to pay for
that because the money has to come from
somewhere doesn't it right I don't think
that's what everyone is saying the other
thing is you're right the thing that is
making life difficult for nurses and for
everyone else is in inflation it's the
bills that are going up and up and up
we've got to tackle inflation that's why
it's the first of my five priorities and
unfortunately in a situation where
you've got high inflation if lots and
lots of people get very large pay
settlements it makes the inflation
problem worse and last longer and that
is not going to help anybody including
nurses and that's why even if it's not
popular it's the right thing for other
countries to stay the course